DAN MCGRATH: Hi,
I'm Dan McGrath.
I'm the product lead for
Google's NoSQL databases.
And I'm here in this session
to give you some insight
into modernizing your HBase
workloads with Clout Bigtable.
But before we get
into that, I want
to give you a quick introduction
into Cloud Bigtable,
and if you're already familiar
with it, talk about some
of the recent additions
to the service.
And to kick that off,
I'm going to give you
a little bit of trivia that you
might not have heard before.
Because this year,
2020, marks 15 years
of Cloud Bigtable being in
production here at Google.
We've spent a lot of time
in that 15 years optimizing
Bigtable from the experience
of running everything
from small zonal workloads to
our largest and most demanding
workloads with deployments
spanning the globe.
Here is a diagram from
a design doc from one
of those very first deployments
of Cloud Bigtable showing
a replicated system
across three regions.
It was the following
year, in 2006,
that Google released the
Bigtable white paper, leading
to the development of HBase.
After beating
production for 10 years,
Cloud Bigtable was released
so companies outside of Google
could benefit from the same
technology used here at Google.
And to make it easier
for developers,
HBase-compatible client
libraries backed by Bigtable
were also released.
Now Cloud Bigtable is a fully
managed NoSQL document service
for use cases where low
latency, random access data,
scalability, and reliability
are very critical.
It seamlessly scales
from your first gigabyte
to data sets that are
at petabyte scales.
It can handle millions
of queries per second.
And as a fully
managed service, it
allows your team to be
freed up from database
and infrastructure
management tasks,
allowing them to dedicate their
time to where the business can
add value.
It's completely compatible
with the existing Apache HBase
setup, enabling seamless
migrations for existing HBase
workloads.
Now Bigtable offers you a
database that provides speed,
scalability, a fully
managed foundation,
and integration in the Google
Cloud and Apache ecosystem
as its core base.
On the speed front,
it does give you
consistent 99th percentile
low latency for random access
reads and writes.
It's the same
technology that powers
a range of billion-user
Google services.
And it's proven in applications
with millions of database
accesses per second.
It easily scales to match
user needs with no downtime.
It's a perfect fit for
real-time storage and analysis
of huge amounts of data.
One of the really nice
things about Cloud Bigtable
is it gives you
consistent performance
as your workload grows.
It can be easily scaled by
simply adding nodes or even
removing nodes within the UI
or command line interface.
It offers seamless
cluster scaling.
So dynamically adding
and removing these nodes
can be done without restarts.
And the storage system
automatically scales as well.
So you only pay for the storage
that you are actively using.
Through the separation of
processing and storage,
Cloud Bigtable is able to
automatically configure
throughput by adjusting the
association of nodes and data.
In the rebalancing
example in the middle,
if node A is
experiencing heavy load,
the routing layer can
move some of the traffic
to a less heavily loaded node,
improving overall performance.
Resizing, in the third
example, comes into play
when a node is added, again
ensuring balanced load
across your nodes, ensuring
best overall throughput
of the system.
It also offers zero-touch
failover for high availability
and a range of other use cases.
Bigtable enables you to write
once to a single replicate
and have it automatically
replicated everywhere
with eventual consistency.
There are no manual steps to
ensure consistency, repair
data, or synchronize
writes and deletes.
It gives you the ability to
have a configurable topology
and policies on how to
route data, both at the read
and write side, to
different replicates.
Common use case for
the replication system
are high availability for
your live serving apps,
or perhaps workload
isolation, where
you have both user serving
and batch workloads running
against the same database.
It's also great for
a use case where
you want latency
optimization to write locally
to a replicate closer
to you, but then
be able to read that
data everywhere,
perhaps in some centralized
replica where all your batch
processing happens.
So let's quickly talk about
some of the recent highlights.
Now on the fully managed
side, Cloud Bigtable
integrates into Cloud IAM for
user access and authentication.
At the end of 2019, we
announced table-level IAM,
allowing you to have more
granular rules on who can
access data within clusters.
We also announced
multi-region replication
to enable you to replicate
data across the globe
as well as a host of new
regions that rolled out
to support Cloud Bigtable.
Earlier this year,
in 2020, we also
announced single-node
production instances.
So historically
with Cloud Bigtable,
you were required
to have three nodes
to be able to be supported by
the service level agreement.
Now you can have a single node
supported by the same SLA that
gives you 99.9% availability
for single-cluster routing
or 99.99% availability
for multi-cluster routing.
Something that I'm really
excited about that we're just
announcing now, in July
2020, is the addition
of managed backups.
So manage backups gives you
a fully automated method
to back up the tables
within your cluster
and then very
quickly restore them,
either into the same
instance, or perhaps you
want to restore them
into a development or QA
cluster for ease of testing.
Now let's have a look at how
you can think about modernizing
both your existing and new HBase
workloads with Cloud Bigtable.
I like to think about it in
terms of two different paths.
One is the backward-looking path
of why you want to modernize.
And this is where
you're currently
struggling to maintain the
availability of your system.
Perhaps you've had
durability issues.
Or perhaps performance,
when scaling the system,
has become toilsome
for your team.
And so an example
of this is where
you're struggling with stability
at scale or during peak load
events.
Or you consider the operational
load on your SRE and DevOps
teams too distracting
from the overall core work
that you're trying to do.
Perhaps the overhead of
managing the replication system,
repairs, and the data
garbage collection system
has also become to
toilsome for your team.
Cloud Bigtable gives
you a great way
to automate away a
lot of those troubles.
The other path where people
typically look at modernization
is forward-looking.
So they want to
move up the stack
and have their development teams
working on something that's
more focused on
the differentiators
that the company offers.
They want to spend
less time and money
managing the complexities
of a distributed database
and have more time to focus
on what was not previously
possible to prioritize.
The really good
thing about looking
at Cloud Bigtable
with HBase is you'll
find most of the concepts map
very seamlessly between the two
systems.
And that's obviously because
of the shared history
both Bigtable and HBase have had
for a long period of time now.
So all the fundamentals are
going to be the same for you.
If you know how to
design schemas on HBase,
you're going to be pretty
good at designing them
on Cloud Bigtable.
Row keys, column families,
column qualifiers,
cells, they're all going to
be the same on Cloud Bigtable.
Even the cases where there are
some differences in the feature
sets that are available,
such as namespaces,
you will find ways
to simulate them
within Cloud Bigtable using
things like row key prefixes.
Now some of the
terminology you're used to,
such as regions, are going
to be slightly different.
We call them tablets
in Cloud Bigtable--
very similar though.
The really good thing
though is all those concerns
are automated and
fully managed for you.
So you don't really need to
worry about them anymore.
Similarly, things like
snapshots, that's now
available as managed backups.
And tasks like compaction--
so you can't configure that,
but it is automatically
managed for you.
So there's no
maintenance work you
need to do on the compaction
and garbage collection sides.
All in all, Cloud Bigtable
supports HBase client libraries
from 1.0 through to 1.3.
So you should find the
development environment
very familiar for you.
Now if you look at the
architecture of Cloud Bigtable,
you'll see a lot of
similarities here as well.
For replicating data,
replication to other clusters
can send different types of
traffic to different clusters.
So we have a way
to set up policies
through a thing called
app profiles that
talk about how failover happens
and how you want to read--
how you want to route your
reads and writes on the system.
Scaling is very simple
in Cloud Bigtable.
It's as simple as
adding nodes or even
removing nodes within the UI
or command line interface.
A table is automatically
sharded into blocks
of rows called tablets.
And this is all managed
behind the scenes.
We use a bunch of
heuristics around total data
size and traffic
to do this for you.
One of the really interesting
things is on the storage side.
This is it automatically
scaling storage system as well,
where they're stored
encrypted, at rest on disk.
And even if you're only
running a single node of Cloud
Bigtable, rest
assured that your data
is durable across
multiple machines.
Now when you're looking
at migrating your existing
workloads into Cloud
Bigtable, the first step
is always around preparation
and planning for the migration.
So typically, you
want to-- going
to do a deep dive into
the different use cases
that you have running on HBase.
And perhaps you'll go
down a different path
for different
types of use cases.
It's really good to build up an
understanding of Cloud Bigtable
and where some of the
concepts and capabilities
might differ than what
the alternatives are.
So you'll want to map concepts,
schema design, queries,
and how you're thinking about
data consistency from HBase
to Cloud Bigtable.
Now there are some
slight differences in
supported functionality between
HBase and Cloud Bigtable.
We have documentation on this.
So I encourage you to read
through the documentation
and have an understanding of
where those differences may
lay early in the process.
Now depending on
the use case, you
could end up going down a
variety of different paths.
Some of them you will
find incredibly easy.
Some of them might require
some more planning upfront.
So we're going to look at
the four different types
of workloads and each of the
different migration strategies.
And we'll walk through them all.
So let's start with batch
load and fast serve.
In this specific
migration path, we only
have a single writing component.
And this simplifies
things a lot.
So this is a batch job that
might be refreshing data
periodically, such as models
that you're serving up.
But then you're using HBase
to have that fast serve
capacity for that data that's
being written into the system.
Now the obvious
first step here is
to update the batch job to write
into both HBase and Bigtable
at the same time.
Once this is done, now you
can spend some time verifying
the batch job to
make sure that it's
writing the same information
into both systems.
After this is done, we can roll
out a change to the API layer
that is reading from
HBase to also support
reading from Bigtable.
Once you're happy with the
performance of the system,
you can cut over to reading
purely from Bigtable
and then update your batch jobs
to stop writing into Bigtable.
At that point in
time, once you're
happy with the
performance, you can
start decommissioning
your old system.
Now, when downtime
is acceptable,
this really simplifies things.
And this is by far the most
common migration path we see.
It works for all types
of HBase workloads
as long as you can
accept a short downtime.
And the downtime will depend
upon the size of the data
that you have in the system.
So obviously, at this point,
you stop writing into HBase
during the migration window.
A slight difference depending
on your type of workload,
you could leave the system
in a read-only state.
Or perhaps you bring down the
entire system for maintenance.
You'll then batch copy the
data from HBase into Bigtable.
And we have things
like Dataflow jobs
that can read sequence files and
do fast loading into Bigtable
for you.
Then you'll want to switch over
your serving path from HBase
to Bigtable, and perhaps do some
calls to check between the two
systems to make sure they're
in a consistent state.
At that time, you can exit
your maintenance window
and resume writing, but now
into the Bigtable system.
A more complex
migration is where
you're migrating with
the system online,
but your data has
a time to live.
And so this is a
common workload pattern
where you're using
Bigtable for something
like more persistent caching.
Or perhaps you have a data
set that has a natural cycle.
Perhaps it's updated every
day and recalculated.
So what this allows
you to do is to have
the code that writes updated
to write into both HBase
and Bigtable with the same
time to live information.
You then simply
wait until the time
to live on all previous data
in the system has expired.
At this point, HBase and Cloud
Bigtable should be in sync.
You can run verification to make
sure everything's performing
as expected on the write path.
Once you're happy with that,
you can update the read side
to start reading
from Cloud Bigtable,
wait for the information to
finish expiring from HBase
once you start writing into it.
And then you should be safe
to decommission your existing
system.
And you've migrated, without
downtime, onto Bigtable.
The last one-- and this
one is more complicated.
This is where you're
migrating a workload that
has persistent data
without downtime.
And so once again,
the first step
here is updating the
write layer of the system.
But you're also going to
want to look at the read
layer of the system.
Once you've got the updates
writing to both HBase
and Bigtable, you'll want to
run a verification that that's
happening correctly and start
batch copying all the existing
information that's in Bigtable.
Once you've migrated
all the information,
you're two systems
should be in sync.
You can then migrate
the read workload,
verify performance
of the system,
and start decommissioning
the old system
at that point in time.
Now this one can take
a little bit longer,
because you have to have
both the dual writing
upfront and then the
backfill operation.
So it's sort of a
combination of some
of these previous approaches.
Now perhaps HBase isn't the only
type of workload you've got.
So if you've got
Cassandra as well,
which is also very
similar to Cloud Bigtable,
I highly encourage you
to tune into our session
on migrating Cassandra
workloads into Cloud Bigtable.
And if you've got DynamoDB,
we have another session
that talks about migrating
that into Bigtable and Cloud
Spanner.
You can also watch
Cloud Bigtable in action
through our showcase demo done
in partnership with Spotify.
I would really encourage
you to look at that demo.
And if you want to get
hands-on and try it yourself,
we have the quick
labs for Bigtable
that you can go through, get
some hands-on experience.
And there is also
the HBase to Bigtable
migration guide, which
walks you through some
of the technical steps
here, commands to run,
and tooling that's available.
So I want to thank you for
tuning into this session
on modernizing
HBase for workloads.
I hope you got
something out of it.
And I'm looking
forward to seeing you
move to a more managed future.